اخبار العالم ايجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره
مرحبا بكم انتشار فتاه بعد قضائها عشره
ايام تحت الانقاض في كهرمان مرعش وحصيله
قتل الزلزال تتجاوز 42 الف انسان في تركيا
وسوريا في حين اعلنت السلطات التركيه
اكتمال عمليه البحث والانقاذ في خمس
ولايات والقبضه على ثلاثه وثلاثين متعهد
بناء دخول المزيد من المساعدات الامميه
الى سوريا من معبر باب الهوى والاتحاد
الدولي الاسطلي بالاحمر والهلال الاحمر
يدعو لتحرك دولي فوري لاحتواء اثار
الزلزال ويؤكد عدم قدره اي منظمه على
الاستجابه للكارثه منفرده في وقت طالب فيه
المبعوث الاممي بعدم تسييس الاستجابه
للطوارئ تحت شعار تركيا قلب واحد اكثر من
700 محطه تلفزيونيه واذاعيه في تركيا
واذربيجان وقبرص التركيه تنجح بجمع سته
مليارات دولار خلال ساعات لمساعده
المتضررين من الزلزال في اكبر حمله تبرعات
في تاريخ تركيا بعيده اتهام الرئيس
التونسي من اعتقلتهم السلطات بالتامر على
الدوله قوات الامن تعتقل المدير السابق
لمكتب رئيس حركه النهضه والاتحاد التونسي
للشغل يؤكد رفضه الاعتقالات الاخيره بينما
طالب الصحفيون التونسيون بالكف عما وصفوه
بالتضييق على الحريات والاعتداء عليهم الى
اللقاء